et aborder la question de la laïcité
comme un problème d'immigration et de
diversité religieuse
ce n'est pas honnête et ce n'est pas
exact ce n'est pas exact parce que la
question de la laïcité et de la
séparation du politique et du religieux
c'est une question centrale dans une
société comme la société québécoise qui
a pas réglé cas pas moi je compare la
laïcité au québec au placenta la
révolution tranquille c'est
l'accouchement
le québec on a accouché du québec
moderne et le placenta de la neutralité
religieuse de la laïcité est resté
accroché et il tombe mais il tombe par
petits bouts ils tombent pas
complètement elle alors cessé ces deux
c'est vraiment de prendre cette se
plaçant à la au fait de prendre 7 7 7
reliques ou ce reliquat où cette
question mal liquidée après la
révolution tranquille de la laïcité et
de dire nous québécois québécoise de
toutes origines d'implantation récente
et moins récentes nous avons une
question à régler qui est jusqu'où
jusqu'où les manifestations religieuses
peuvent-elles et doivent-elles se
manifester dans la place dans les
institutions publiques